president biden left americans behind in
afghanistan and now his administration's
being accused of stealing credit for
getting people out the state department
says it helped facilitate the safe
departure of a stranded american mother
and her three kids but army veteran
corey mills and his team who risked
their lives to bring them to safety say
the federal government had very little
to do with it
that comes as the taliban is reportedly
preventing at least six planes at an
airport in northern afghanistan from
taking off
secretary of state tony blinken claims
the taliban's not blocking americans
from leaving and says the biden
administration is working with the
terror group
they said that they will let people with
travel documents freely depart
we will hold them to that
so will dozens of other countries
the international community is watching
to see
if the taliban will live up to their
commitments without personnel on the
ground
we can't verify the accuracy of
manifests
the identities of passengers flight
plans or aviation security protocols
so this is a challenge
and if you think the situation is bad in
afghanistan now general mark milley says
things could get a lot worse
my military estimate is is that the
conditions are
likely to develop
of a civil war i don't know if the
taliban is going to be able to
consolidate power and establish
governance i think there's at least
a very good probability of a broader
civil war and that will then in turn
lead to conditions that could in fact
lead to a reconstitution of al qaeda or
a growth of isis or other myriad of
terrorist groups
so judge
blinken got to be the worst secretary of
state in my lifetime
and i was alive for john kerry
you know what i think he's the worst
secretary of state ever if you've got if
you've got a secretary of state who's
more worried about whether or not we're
a racist nation and running to the u.n
and saying at a time when he should be
worrying about this he should be
worrying about our exit from banistant
he should be yelling from the roofs
you've got to get my people out before
you get the military out and instead
he's over at the u.n diddling on this
whole issue of that you know we're a
racist nation help us convince ourselves
we're racist the guy's a liar i don't
believe a word he says he says that the
taliban is is agreeing or facilitating
the movement of america's out of there
he's wrong he's a liar you lie once you
you have the absolute right to believe
they're lying again that's what i used
to tell juries all the time and that's
the case right now harold ford so
biden teams saying we're not aware of
you know any stranded americans we're
not aware of this well they weren't
aware of the taliban takeover either so
either they don't know what's happening
and it's happening or they're lying
about it that's why their credibility's
shot
well first it's good to be back at the
table
good to be with you
good to see the magnificent you really
missed a couple good weeks
the magnanimity is not left the uh uh
i'd say a couple of things judge i def i
differ slightly if you'd have told me on
august 24th
that we would have gotten 120 000
americans out i would have disputed it
in fact i came on another show in our
network to be critical of how things had
taken place and how they'd unfold it now
this doesn't mean that oversight should
take place they're going to be democrats
in the house and the senate who've
already called for it as a matter of
fact for us to figure out what happened
why it happened even some democrats
saying how could we spend a trillion
dollars in the military and the security
forces in afghanistan run like they did
and not be prepared i think we'll get
answers and democrats will hold them
accountable as well
but
i don't lose sight of the fact that we
still did the right thing by leaving and
secretary blinken um i don't i disagree
with the characterization about him
being the worst secretary of state i
think there's a lot of frustration
there's a lot of anger
there's a lot of anger look there's a
there's a competition for worse and we
can have another show to deal with that
but i think that they have done
they didn't do everything right and
there's no doubt they will be held
accountable but when you look at where
we are today we have to make sure anyone
we get out of there tomorrow or the
following days we need to vet them i
think that there is no doubt there's
been those on this network and others
who have showed who said that there's no
reason in the world where we should not
be extra careful after we've gotten all
of our americans out that anyone wanting
to come now we have to make sure they
indeed are the ones who helped us and if
their security their security vetting is
you're jumping the issue the issue to
get out everybody agrees on the issue of
vetting everybody agrees on the hairy
issue that we all agree on at this table
i think is that they did it in the most
hasty and unsafe way they could have 13
servicemen are dead men and women are
dead because they were like sitting
ducks in an open area in a cosmopolitan
city instead of the bagram air base
because they made a political decision
and not a military decision i don't
agree with you i don't disagree with
that's not what jesse asked me i happen
to think that there were mistakes made
all along the way
general milky as well as
secretary austin both said that we will
get to the bottom of that there will
come a time to do that at this point i
agree with all around the table how do
we get people out safely and how do we
ensure that they're vetted before they
come here and then let the chips fall
where they may be in terms of
accountability all right so the democrat
editors dana at the new yorker magazine
are saying democrats of the biden state
department are blocking americans from
leaving afghanistan how will the fact
checkers resolve that what do you do
when that happens what do you do that is
so hard it's so hard you might take a
day off
we're in this bizarre dystopian
situation where the biden administration
is trying to like pretend that this
crisis isn't happening
they i know they want to focus on other
things we're going to talk about that in
a later block but
americans stuck in afghanistan because
of your actions that does not mean they
are a political inconvenience
okay they are stuck and they need help
and then we're having this weird
semantic debate about what is a hostage
imagine this if you are on a plane in
afghanista or in afghanistan you have a
plane you
want to leave you are cleared to leave
you have the paperwork to leave and the
taliban won't let you leave
what would you consider yourself
stranded and a hostage
the taliban
is preventing them from leaving like so
you can imagine let's just say things
were reversed let's say this were
president under president trump's watch
and the very same things happened what
do you think chuck schumer would be
saying today he was saying that
you created a hostage crisis and they
would be
banging the drums on that the other
thing i would say is we didn't get 120
000 americans out we didn't get all the
americans out we got 120 000 people out
correct but we only got 7
of the interpreters and the helpers of
the americans out that is what i think
that's what i think is a real moral
outrage yeah so 93 percent of the guys
that came over
basically got to the front of the line
and none of the service dogs and none of
the dogs none of the dogs greg well a
lot of the dogs would come back
fact checkers i just was very impressed
with the with the first question that
you came out with is he the worst
secretary of state ever because it
actually created a debate
that we had to accept that that was out
there it would be like me saying um am i
the greatest talk show host ever you
have people are asking that question
yeah not me that's right not me but some
people first of all to you to your point
about like well the people being
afghanistan the americans that's their
choice that's like a doctor saying to a
patient that after a patient died to the
family well you know he was a smoker
yeah you know he was a couple with
pounds overweight so you know they're
like basically kind of saying it's on
them yeah we put out 19 state department
cables we told them to come you know and
then but there are people disputing that
also can we ban the phrase finally the
world is watching because nobody cares
if the world is watching the entire you
know the entire taliban government right
now is has not a single non-taliban
member right and they're still beating
the crap out of people in protest or
going around doing nasty things so the
whole world is watching means nothing if
you don't do anything after you're
watching it's like people hold up
smartphones while you're being attacked
it's like could you help me put down the
phone and help you big jerks this is
it goes back to everybody agrees the
decision we were into the implementation
awful this is so royally screwed up it's
almost impossible to unscrew it it's
like a car accident you can't reverse it
and get the car back right you just hope
that the insurance company will total it
so you don't ever get that car that
never is quite the same so i think that
like there's no way to undo this so now
we're kind of uh and we didn't
we didn't accept this but we're now
along for the ride there's no choice
there's really when you see the general
not even sure nobody even knows
precisely how many americans are there
they're not even sure what's going on
and we're so we have to be there i mean
we just have to sit there and deal with
it we have no intel we're told uh what
the taliban are doing by
by the taliban and we're telling them
what we want please don't hurt the
americans and we'll reward you so we're
the first nation in history to actually
extort ourselves
sorry go ahead
i had one more thing but i thought it
was great but i'll save it for one more
one thing about what you were just
saying there the uh on the world is
watching yeah today when the taliban
announced their government and their
cabinet they're like all on the u.n
terrorism watch list yeah exactly
exactly is the world watching who cares
if the world's watching yes who's the
world anyway exactly i don't want to
name specific countries i've gotten in
trouble for that before but we know who
we're talking the world as an entity is
overrated right you talk to any space
aliens have you seen the world
not too good hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else